[Music]
today with our allies we embark on an
operation of unparalleled importance to
establish a beachhead at Normandy and
rollback the German aggression that has
terrorized Europe for the past five
years we are all that separates the
world from darkness
it's so much more than a chance to be
heroes in our own lifetimes we prevail
our triumphs will be etched into the
hearts and minds of a grateful world or
untold generations I'm talking about
glory gentlemen true glory Colonel Davis
sure can't give a nice speech his pep
talk reminded me of the one coach
Johnson gave us on our Thanksgiving Day
game versus Austin I'm sure you remember
we lost that game by 42 points
always looking over Pierson shoulders
lieutenant Turner he's got him on a
tight leash but it appears some breaks
free we'll all get bit
ever since I could hold a rifle I wanted
to be like you Paul you've always been a
tough act to follow but I'm damn sure
gonna try
it's now or never
hey I wish I was coming home to her yeah
just wait till we do Paris seems like a
long way off remember
no digging it at the shore gotta advance
you need to stay low and do not bunch up
stick to your trainings you're gonna
make it through a proud look at you
fellas into battle anytime anywhere all
right boys beaches are supposed to be
flattened right
don't scare private no sir it should be
Daniel got a light sure thing
no stay on mission
taking the stage we want to print this I
can't see the line bar
you heard the lieutenant
Oh
guys stay blend get to the Seawolf
lawyer
everybody ready here we go
drop the rabbit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get your right down and keep
take a bangalore and get to the seawall
Daniel this is what you trained for now
pick up that banner you can do this yes
sir oh Jesus
hurry before they reload move it
[Music]
use the banger I'll cover you after we
breach
keep pushing towards the bunker
[Music]
that will look bad here take this thanks
bud here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't leave the target area
and up the left
Daniel Sussman up here
[Applause]
Daniel's I need your husband to take
point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]